my name is David village and I'm the
chief of me mentality at UCSF and I'm
going to give you a little tour of some
of the new care and treatment that were
providing for babies that are at risk
for neurological injury
you
one of the newer treatments it's become
hypothermia in which the baby's body
temperature is reduced a few degrees
below normal but just that slight
reduction in temperature is associated
with the better neurological outcome in
some patients this treatment is
currently offered to term babies that
have had evidence of a lack of oxygen
around the time of birth and how that is
actually being implemented is that
you'll notice the babies laying down on
a blue blanket and that is a water
cooled blanket which will maintain
temperature at about 33 point five
degrees centigrade and normal body
temperature is about 37 degrees
centigrade so we're making the baby
hypothermic which means a lower than the
normal body temperature now you notice
that the baby also has a kind of white
cap on and there's some wires coming out
from the cap and that is one of the
monitoring leads that we use for the
electroencephalogram or EEG which will
monitor the baby's brain activity and
that can be helpful in telling us the
extent of brain injury and also whether
their seizures along with that the baby
is also having a 24 hour video taken and
that also helps us to assess
having seizures and so we have a lot of
equipment around the bedside it's really
all about trying to monitor the baby's
vital signs and also monitor the baby's
brain activity well we have the
capability of monitoring on a 24/7 basis
brain function very few units in the
country are using this monitoring so I
would say that if we could encourage
brain monitoring like we monitor
temperature and blood pressure in the
Newport we would be able to pick up so
many more of these disabling disorders
that occur in the nursery unbeknownst to
us if we're monitoring the brain
continuously we'll be able to pick that
up if we pick it up we can treat it if
we treat it we may potentially reduce
the burden of that particular over here
we have a baby who is being monitored
with amplitude integrated EEG CFM and
this is an extremely premature baby born
in 26 weeks gestational age most of the
babies that we have cared for and
also been using some of the monitoring
techniques to monitor extremely
premature babies very closely as well I
think that the first few days of life
and a premature baby are pretty
important to watch closely so we've been
trying to use as many means as possible
to monitor these babies closely but most
importantly our ultimate goal is to
develop rationale therapies that can be
used in the nursery that will reduce the
lifelong burden of some of these disease
processes like stroke we've had great
success with the cooling trials the
hypothermia for a newborn brain injury
in the term baby population but that's
only the beginning of trying to affect
that process
you